Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for another Monday morning podcast for Monday.
What would that be?
16 set Monday the 18th February 18th.
And uh,
we don't have guests on here to
demote lately more as I've gotten older here starting to lose my mind and I get
self conscious about you guys listening to me going on and on and on.
I do have a special guest,
someone I've got to know last year or maybe a little bit more than than a year
ago.
We did a movie called the front runner.
Please welcome director extraordinary or Jason Reitman.
Now I have to admit,
is Jason as a fan of your podcast that I am disappointed by myself even being
here.
Cause I hate when you have a guest on the podcast,
my favorite episodes of the ones are just you and your,
and you're talking to yourself and you're your best guest and you go,
Oh really?
Bill?
Yeah.
And you like go back and forth.
So I'm frustrated with myself being here on your part.
Okay,
well don't worry this thing by listeners.
Fortunately enjoy music,
movies,
music and that type of thing.
So when I do have people on,
I don't,
I try not to have just some sort of random person and I'm having you on not only
cause I love the movie you made,
I'm also in it for a minute.
So this is held in a minute.
So this is also like self serving
here.
You're great in the movie.
Like you're genuinely great in the movie and I've gotten a lot of feedback on
that and you're not only in it for a minute,
like you play,
you have,
you have a good run down an alley a couple of times.
I,
you have one of the best scenes in the film,
one of the best scenes in the film.
And one of the first things that people ever talk about is the,
is the beat where you drop the uh,
uh,
the notepad and they started talking about your scene and your character in it.
And I thought you were fantastic.
Oh,
I know.
And everybody,
uh,
yeah.
That was the one thing that people said like a,
well,
let's just let them know what it's about in case,
you know,
because God knows there's a million things to watch.
Um,
Jason Director movie last year called the,
uh,
the front runner,
which was the Gary Hart story,
which I didn't know that,
um,
up until when he ran for president that mainstream media,
meaning like the New York Times,
the La Times,
Chicago Tribune,
whatever,
like the newspapers that you paperboard delivered never delved into.
MMM.
A political candidate's personal life as far as their,
their affairs or,
or,
or whatever was going on.
Even if they knew,
even if they knew what it was considered beneath them.
Scumbag journalism,
like a,
um,
national enquirer level stuff.
I had no idea.
MMM.
I guess it was something I never really thought about.
Like whether they,
uh,
because growing up I felt like the only person who ever did it was JFK.
Cause that's what you always heard about him or about him?
Marilyn Monroe.
Yeah.
But you never heard about anybody else.
So I just sort of assumed that,
oh,
he screwed around.
MMM.
There was a couple of legendary guys that screwed around that screwed around so
much that everybody kind of knew.
So I,
I thought that,
I guess I kind of thought that screwing around with sort of a new thing,
right.
Or whatever.
So
how we feel about sex in general,
I mean,
you know,
as we get older we realize that,
oh,
that's right.
More people are probably pervs than we thought.
And most people cheat than we thought.
And you go back in history.
Oh yeah.
People would probably been doing these things since the dawn of man when I was
really young.
I was taking drum lessons from this guy and he was,
he was 70 then
and I was like 18 or 19,
and I was taking drums.
He's all big band drummer.
And he would start telling me stories one time.
Um,
he was like,
oh yeah.
He goes,
I used to have,
he goes this,
I knew this,
uh,
this is a woman.
She had green eyes,
man.
She was crazy.
It's the East a banger in the park up against the tree.
And I was like,
listen to this shit bag,
a drum lesson.
Well we got to know each other after a while we'd hang out and stuff.
So this,
he didn't give a shit.
He told me cause I was fascinated with his life cause I wanted to on some level
it's like,
wait,
is this what I knew I wanted a fun job and I knew I love drums but I,
I didn't have it.
I was like more like dad rock band sort of talent level.
But I didn't know that at that point.
And I was fascinated because he had lived that life.
He,
he and he went through the whole big band era and all of that and watch that go
away and how he dealt with it and all that stuff.
But he used to tell me these stories and I remember I looked at him like you did
that,
what was that like?
Like the 1930 [inaudible] 1930 [inaudible] 1940 [inaudible] and like you did
that.
And he goes,
let me tell you something kid.
He goes,
every generation thinks they're the first generation that ever fucked.
And I was,
and I never forgot that.
I love the wording on that too.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
But then you of course you go back and you,
you know,
if you're the Romans,
Greeks and all that stuff,
you really,
it seems like it was like nothing happened.
Like nobody had sex between the Romans and the Greeks right up until a
Woodstock,
right.
Is kind of how it goes.
So anyway,
so what's his face?
Scary heart get has an affair with Donna Rice and the Miami Herald decides to
cross that line.
And ever since then,
uh,
we now have what we have now where they just stay,
just delve into everybody's life and sports it now with like social media.
I just thought it was just such a,
the way you did it,
it was just such a great story considering everything that's happening now,
you know,
like almost like everything's out there now.
Um,
to go back and kind of be like,
this was sort of like the first,
like I can't even say leak in the dyke.
This was just the thing that kind of blew it open.
Yeah.
No,
and by the way,
I didn't know this stuff either.
I'm not exactly a student of history.
I'm a student of movies.
I like movies and I didn't know the story and I frankly didn't really know who
Gary Hart was.
You know,
I was probably 10 when this happened.
And,
uh,
there was a radio lab not to plug in different podcasts,
sorry.
But that's all right.
Radio have a,
isn't a radio lab.
Everybody.
I did a piece on this story,
Matt by had written a book,
uh,
about Gary Hart.
And that really was my introduction to the story and considering everything that
we're going through right now and considering the way that we've of a thin the
line between what is a private life and what is a public life.
And I thought this story was fascinating,
that there was a moment where as you just said,
he's,
his private life was out of bounds.
It was considered not only uncouth,
but it just wasn't our business.
And he's a guy who was actually a great candidate in every other respect.
Uh,
you know,
two term senator and was kind of just the,
not only the presumed nominee but presumed to when,
you know,
he was like 10 points ahead of George Bush going into the campaign.
Yeah.
Plus we had just had eight years of Republican.
So then that,
that's what happens.
And everybody's like,
oh,
it's the red ties fault,
right.
Can go and then you go eight years this way,
then eight years that way.
So
yeah.
And,
and the story kind of broke so,
so basically,
yeah,
you're right.
Other than,
you know,
people kind of knew about Gary Hart,
the,
I think there was kind of presumptions that perhaps he was a womanizer that
perhaps he dated around,
you know,
he'd been separated from his wife for a couple of times.
And so he had,
he had kind of just dated traditionally in DC and,
and the Miami Herald,
what is dated traditionally means he's separated and I mean,
don't want to say he wasn't,
there was a moment where he wasn't married and he was just kind of going on
dates and so people got to feel for what this guy is like as a,
as a bachelor guy crushes it at work,
he crushes it outside when he was a handsome guy,
him and his best friend was Warren Beatty.
I mean,
you know,
uh
Oh wow.
Yeah,
there you go.
So,
uh,
the Miami Herald gets wind of this and they,
they followed it up and when a lot of other newspapers said,
you know,
we're not gonna,
we're not gonna cover this.
The Miami Herald did,
an American public said,
yes,
give me more of that.
And it coincides with just a lot of things happening simultaneously.
You know,
uh,
it was just a few years before that CNN even like went on the air.
They started crossfire.
This satellite van was invented a current affair.
The first gossip television show,
you know,
goes on,
goes on the air suit.
So the,
you know,
what we think of is,
national enquirer being a print medium,
like made it to television and now we're filling a 24 hour news cycle and the
American public said,
yeah,
that that matters to us.
We want to,
we want to hear.
And that was also too,
back then before the 24 hour news channel,
you had time shit was coming out.
You at least,
you know,
if it was eight in the more like this fucking stories breaking in 11 hours we
got it.
We got to over 10 hours,
we got to do something here and now you have like forget about the 24 hours.
So you have social media and now also the way people post news,
there is no alleged.
It's like somebody gets accused of something and then regular people because
they're not in journalism.
And then I guess there's,
there's no libel or anything on the Internet.
It's just be,
you know,
so-and-so accused of this and then it's like the next generation of that piece
of shit.
Blahblahblahblahblah did this and um,
oh,
sorry.
That's me.
Uh Oh shit.
This is literally,
this is the part of the podcasts that you enjoy.
When I fucking go onto my phone here and completely a
175 pounds,
we'll say,
there we go.
Is this your way in?
No,
I'm doing Santa Barbara Tonight and I'm flying the helicopter up with my
instructor and I thought we only got to get the two seater.
Now the four seater became available.
So I'm asking if my,
my buddy can go along.
So he just needs to know how many is there going to be and how much he weighs
because it's all waiting
single.
Anytime you rent a helicopter or take a helicopter,
you have to admit your weight.
Does that funk with paypal?
Uh,
yeah.
You know what?
It's funny because especially in this business with entertainers.
Yeah.
Cause I had a buddy of mine,
he goes and he was sort of fad at the time,
fatter than he wanted to be.
And he goes,
dude,
I'll be like one 90 by the time we fly.
I think he was over to bills and he didn't want to admit it and I just said,
I just said,
dude,
this is not a time to lie.
He came back,
he's like two oh six but I'm going to be in the one nineties by the time we fly
it's like great,
just don't,
you know,
don't gain any more weight or whatever.
And what they do is they'll just adjust like five pounds up or something like
that.
I would think
dome,
they're moving weight around the helicopter to balance it left right top bottom
and then how much fuel you can have.
Like there was a,
there was some kid who was inexperienced or whatever and he filled up the thing
that I was uh,
and I'm going to fly the are 44 so it's a four passenger.
When you have a four passenger,
I mean unless you have kids,
you know,
I haven't flown this thing much.
I'm just repeating what people told me.
You never feel both tanks up full cause you just have too much weight and you
won't be able to get lift.
And I don't even know who this guy even got into a Harvard,
but somehow we did and he took off.
And then it just becomes this thing where you're just,
you're just pulling too much power and you're,
you're,
uh,
you start descending and then your brain tells you pull more,
which you actually want to do is try to level out what she probably should have
done was something called a running landing,
which is sort of sliding into second base.
Um,
which he did not do.
And unfortunately it didn't end well that day.
So that's why we're asking.
He's asking how many more?
It's only one,
only one is not a big deal.
And also he's in,
he's like a buck 75,
so it won't be a problem,
but it will definitely,
you know,
I would think he wouldn't talk off both at this point.
But um,
but it's,
it's not that long a flight.
My DP is a pilot and I said,
and Parker was a pilot.
A lot of my camera crew,
we are pilots and on up in the air,
uh,
which we did with American Airlines,
they took the whole camera team down to Dallas at the end of the shoot.
And they have,
I guess this warehouse where they have a cockpit simulator for every plane they
have in their fleet and they just start putting them into planes.
And these cockpits are real,
I mean they are completely outfitted that it costs millions of dollars and
they're so good that if you,
if you get certified on the simulator,
you are ready to take passengers up in the air.
Like there was no inbetween as soon as you're certified on the,
no.
What I don't understand about that is how do they duplicate the feel of whatever
you're flying and how do they duplicate like turbulence and then not only that,
you know,
no matter what,
you're not to do
die in that thing.
Right.
So you've never had to mentally try to keep your shit together.
I speak.
So I would think you,
you have to go up with somebody.
You got to,
you don't think they go.
All right buddy,
here's your space invaders.
Huc in a certificate.
Eric says,
my scenario,
Eric,
he,
he said he's never sweat more in his life.
He said,
you forget that it is fake the moment it is happening because it's all while it,
the whole thing is shaking the whole time.
The whole thing can rotate and move and shake.
They got screens all around.
So all you see is what you would be normally seeing outside the window.
I got into that and what they did is they were just fucking with him the whole
time.
So with each one of the guys on my camera team,
they would just throw everything you left engine's out.
You know,
a Burgess went through your under tornado coming.
They gave everyone the Sally route to see if they could no one,
no one to kill.
Everyone was just crashing in the river and Oh God,
yeah.
Oh that's in Dallas,
Huh?
Yeah.
And then when we were shooting front runner,
uh,
we were over at Delta and they,
cause the delta is in Atlanta.
And,
uh,
I remember on a lunch break,
the guys did the same thing.
Is that,
and I missed out,
I didn't know this was going down.
They came back from lunch and Eric was,
she,
his hands were shaking cause he said it's just,
it's so real.
You forget that you're in a simulator and it's exactly
right.
Well hopefully somebody listens to this and let's be try to do something like
that.
Cause I always,
every represents like nine 11 with those,
you know,
the terrorists taking over the place.
You have your Steven Seagal fantasy that she would take them all out.
But then in my fantasy,
the pilots are also taken out and then that's where it ends.
It's like I could fly a plane,
no.
Oh,
okay.
Now and I don't,
and there's a lot of stuff that,
um,
is involved with it that I don't understand that does fascinates me as far as
their flaps and that type of stuff as far as like,
you know,
because the weird thing about aviation as you kind of learn through people
fucking up in most of the time those fuck ups lead to death.
And it's not something that you want to,
it's like,
it's,
I'd equate it to like riding a motorcycle where if,
you know,
yeah,
if you'd sell it,
you'll going person you want to talk to about riding a motorcycle is somebody
else who rides a motorcycle cause they'll talk about the fun of it and where to
go.
Anybody else,
no matter when you know that a win,
right.
Same thing with like aviation,
which is not a fair comparison because of how safe it is.
Um,
I mean there's always obviously an element of danger every time you do it,
but like the,
the,
just the sheer amount of people that are up there versus down here,
there's nobody up there texting and,
and also the level of training and the level of just communication that goes on
when you're up there.
I mean,
that's what always blows by and after every flight is when I then go down the
highway and you know,
out here,
uh,
upwards of six lanes of breasts and it's just like,
I'm literally flying in formation right now on the ground people,
I don't know what their flight plan is.
I don't know what they're to do.
People are just ignoring the rules.
Like those people who pass you on the right doing like 95 miles an hour and
you're trying to get off.
Um,
and I can't tell you how many times I've landed,
got in my car and then got on the highway and seen an accident.
That's happened like four times.
I saw the craziest accident day I was on the 10 and two cars try to merge into
the same lane.
They both notice each other at the same time and they don't touch,
their car's never make contact,
but they both freak out by how close they are doing for other actors.
And one overcorrect left goes into the media and the other one over corrects
right roles,
their car.
Oh,
cross up into his sign up onto the dirt and I'm just behind them.
Three quarters between both of them and just go right between them.
It was an episode of the fall guy.
It was like transforms.
It was so crazy and they never touched each other.
It was the freakiest thing.
It was like the hand of God.
It was a,
it spooked me for a while after because it's just so strange.
I remember early in my career I did a road gig with the comic would broken his
hip in a car accident and he drove like an old lady and like I was like,
what the fuck?
And then I started driving and I could just feel him how nervous he was.
And that was the first time that clicked in my head,
the physics of what I was doing.
Like I,
this car is going 80 so am I,
you know,
I'm going 80 miles on you.
Like you just don't think it.
You just sit in there cruising along and all you're gauging is what's in front
of you and well it's clear so it doesn't feel like you're going 80 miles and
like I'm,
I'm going,
my body is traveling at a rate that if I was to hit something and stop abruptly,
my brain's going to slam it against the inside of my skull and I'm going to be
dead.
Like,
that's just not something that I think,
and this happens in aviation to when,
when guys get higher and higher,
ours is,
you get that false sense of safety.
Like they,
what I heard an in ground school was the most dangerous pilots where the people
with very few hours and then people with a ton of hours because then they would
get lazy with their preflight,
you know,
cause it,
they never had an engine failure.
Never.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Let's go fucking load it up.
You fine.
What do you weigh?
Fucking bucks.
60 bucks.
70 to get it in the fucking thing and um,
you know,
and just,
just doing dumb shit.
You know,
why aren't there more?
It's funny when I think about it,
there's plenty of stories,
horror stories about musicians on the road.
So many musicians have died,
plane crashes,
car crashes,
or you can just Kinda,
you just in your mind,
I say that you can kind of instantly lists like 20 of them,
right?
I don't know the stories about comics,
but comics are on the road just as much because we fly commercial.
Most of most of those guys,
I think that died.
A lot of those.
They were,
they were chartering planes.
Like the,
the day the music died.
Like that was the whole thing.
Let's get that.
And all of that was,
because I remember I played that room,
the surf ballroom,
and I flew into that airport,
the whole thing.
It was like,
Jews,
you're going to fly into that airport.
He'll get like,
they think it's the,
it's like,
no,
what happened was,
as far as what I read was just the technology for de icing just was not there.
So it,
he had the added weight on his wings of the ice and then also the ice,
just the layer of it changes the shape of the wing,
which affects your level of lift.
And he had those two devastating combinations.
And then,
then the,
the end result of that equation was they all died.
So,
um,
yeah,
I'm,
I don't know that there's,
I think Leonard Skinner was another one.
I think Aerosmith had just chartered that plane or was going to chart,
that was a shit plane.
You see they found Arrowsmith original tour van.
No,
apparently they found original like tiny tour van would like spray painted on
the side or something.
Like how does that exist for that long for,
so somebody just doesn't,
I would just think that the plot,
it had no idea who Aerosmith was.
Right.
It says it on the side of the van.
Yeah.
And just had it in the back and like,
I don't know if that was a brand crump company or what tilt is that fucking,
that's,
that's the,
that should be in like the rock and roll hall of fame or something.
Uh,
the sets from 2001 sat in a field forever in England.
like all these old spaceships and uh,
and spacecraft and,
and things that they build miniatures.
Uh,
but we're just like enormous manger.
Apparently we're sitting in a field for years in England.
That's what I find fascinating about when I was talking to you when we had the
time when we were doing front runner,
was talking to you about growing up in this business.
And when I listened to you talking about movies and movie sets,
I was fascinated because you sound like me the way I talked about sports and
football cards and guys who played in old stadiums and that type of stuff.
And,
um,
did your parents ever,
uh,
try to discourage you from getting into this business?
I would say that a lot cause I don't think I would do that to my daughter
because I just look at it like this is an incredibly fun business.
It's,
it's really hard and it's very competitive.
But so I think if you're going to try to get to the top of any business,
you're gonna deal with that same thing.
It's not like trying to become the greatest oil man or politics or the best
lawyer.
I would think that all of that becomes cutthroat.
The higher up you're going up the mountain.
So,
I mean,
if you're really into this,
uh,
this business,
I mean,
I just,
plus I also don't think it's as bad as it used to be as far as now with like all
of this,
uh,
the power that the individual has on social media that if somebody is a creek,
because that was the big thing,
especially if you had a daughter,
he's like,
you're not getting into this business casting couch,
all of those horror stories of that shit.
Now I think it's,
it's,
um,
I've,
I've just declared on my podcast that it's,
it's,
it's okay.
No,
that's what I did and I just decided that's how I do it.
I mean,
I honestly,
I think the,
the rejection,
the potential for rejection is more dangerous then I guess partying and all that
stuff.
I,
I think,
uh,
if I,
you know,
if my daughter was thinking of going into business,
that would be my biggest fear is just going to a business where,
you know,
decade by decade you're being told you're worthless or were told,
um,
that,
uh,
your value list on a daily basis.
That's no way to live.
But my parents actually,
I think that's literally said,
oh,
that's just something that gets in your head by not booking auditions.
Yeah.
I mean unlike any other business where you can kind of see,
you know,
judge your own where's by how you're doing,
uh,
these are business.
Yeah.
You go to audition after audition,
uh,
or you write something one after night and you don't really have a sense of why
you're not being picked or why your work is not being made.
And so you start to second guess and look in the mirror and go,
oh,
is it this?
Is it that,
you know,
is it because I wore this is because I'm too heavy as it,
maybe I need to look more like this person or sound more like this person.
I went through a hell of that.
I bet.
I think that's the fork in the road where you can really go into a deep
depression,
which I did.
Or you can grow from it where you just go like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
This is what I do.
This is what I look like.
And that's how once I went to that mindset,
this is what I do.
This is what I look like.
If you want to book me,
awesome.
If you don't,
I understand.
There's all kinds of beautiful piece we're allowed there.
Yeah,
always.
I mean,
one thing I've learned from listening to your podcast though is that you have,
and I'm not sure if these developed earlier or later,
but you have a strong sense of self reflection and,
and,
and you probably don't like to be saying this,
but I think you're,
you're incredibly thoughtful when it comes to that.
Uh,
and,
and really healthy compliments are not allowed on this now.
I know,
I know.
Sorry.
No,
I do.
I'm,
I'm a,
yeah.
Neil was telling me I have to get better at doing that,
so thank you.
I appreciate it.
But there was,
I went through,
um,
in the,
uh,
okay.
So when I started,
the look was,
it was just the post eighties,
but that look was still around the sport coat with the Miami vice colored tee
shirt.
And the sleeves pulled up a little bit.
And I remember my mother got me a sport coat to wear on stage and I knew it
would look good,
but I didn't think I was good enough to wear it.
So I don't if that's the Catholic guilt or whatever.
So I never wore it.
She got me that great.
I didn't,
I,
it's fucking hilarious.
I didn't think I was good enough to dress like a hacky fucking road comic
because at that point it was like 93 and 94 so that look was way out and like,
um,
is that jacket looks still at your folks' house or,
you know,
I'm trying to think where the,
I think I might,
they might be at my parents house or it was,
it was,
uh,
given away or something.
But,
um,
then the,
the,
the grunge thing came in so everybody had to have their shirts on tucked.
And then the late nineties was a real moose era.
There was a lot of moose in the hair.
And I remember,
you know,
that was back in the days of the black and white photos.
Right.
So I had booked a little bit of acting work early in my career.
And if you're young and you book anything,
I booked a or something like that,
all of a sudden they're just like,
oh Jesus.
Well you know,
this must be the next young horse we can write.
Yeah.
So they started,
I had a little buzz,
you know,
new guy in New York,
whatever.
So I would hand out,
you know,
they handed out my,
my photos and this back when I had hair and with the Moose and the hair,
my hair looked brown.
So on some lower budget shit they would bring me in for like the lead or
something.
And there was sort of an unwritten rule that redheaded males or just you're not
the lead,
you're the friend.
So I would walk in,
you know,
prepared like the three scenes or whatever and they'd come walking in their face
that drop and be like,
okay,
we're just going to do the first thing.
And that happened a million times and I'd be like,
but I,
but I prepared off.
Nobody would just,
yeah,
maybe if you read for his friend or something.
And I,
um,
it was funny cause I never quite got frustrated because I knew what was going
on.
I figured it out after a couple of times of that happening,
like,
oh,
I get it,
I look like fucking Ron Howard and they think,
you know,
I'm not this guy and I just always had in my head eventually I'm going to get
that part.
And,
but my goals were all stand up related anyways.
And I knew that my standup was going to lead to me meeting someone like you and
hopefully getting a partner in a movie.
So that's what I ended up doing.
I just focused on stand up and stand up and stand up and stand up.
And then eventually I pushed through and I think,
uh,
I would say Vince Gilligan was the first guy with breaking bad.
I finally got to play an asshole.
I got to play an asshole.
And I liked,
what I liked about playing that asshole was I had Hule so I didn't have to act
tough.
Right.
It's like I got this guy,
so I just had to be the reasonable that I come on,
man,
this guy,
he's going to get upset,
just fucking sign this thing.
I remember actually onset because there's a dynamic that was in my head and I
think that often happens as a director I was saying in their head,
but they're not communicating it enough to the actors or whoever.
And I had this dynamic in my head of what you and Steve's,
this is where do we each other.
And I remember the moment where you suddenly got what I w why I thought the two
of you would be great together.
Like why I thought this was an interesting comic pairing as two people at a
newspaper who worked together.
Right.
You know,
one guy who your character who had under actually done a lot of undercover work
and uh,
was kind of more tough as nails,
but uh,
but also maybe talking it up a little too much.
And then the other guy that had never been undercover,
I had never done in any type of investigation and,
and what that work would be like together.
Well that was a fun guy to be that guy,
like a saying that he did more than he did because I go the other way.
I,
I underplay and that's,
and I'm telling you,
that comes from where I was born in the world growing up just outside of Boston,
Massachusetts.
You know,
look in the way I did with fucking orange hair and shit.
The,
the move was underplaying self deprecation,
right?
Funny yourself before it was on.
You make the bigger kids who could beat the shit out of you,
laugh.
So they like you.
And in that moment when they're going to somebody up,
they look at you and then move on to the next kid.
That's what it was all about was just getting it off of me.
It was like,
what was that came the wonder ball?
You know,
when you're a kid that wind up ball goes round and round.
Just making sure when that song ended,
you weren't holding on that.
Yeah,
you weren't holding the ball.
So,
um,
you know,
it's funny,
in my school,
the redheaded guy in my class was,
the tough guy was,
his name was Paris.
Crone.
And he was the son of the lead singer for Reo Speedwagon
and uh,
he was the tough guy.
He was easily the,
the toughest dude in class.
He's probably a sweetheart now,
but he was a bully back then.
And so that was my association with redhead head through elementary school.
That's what I love about kids who grew up in like Hollywood and La out here.
Like the people you went to fucking see.
This is why I love being out here.
It's not meeting the guy,
it's meeting the relatives or some,
like I went one time I went to a Superbowl party and I met this guy.
His grandfather played the guy who was in the bed with the Horse Head in the
Godfather.
That's amazing analysis going.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
So like whenever people like shit on La Going,
oh,
this is a bunch of photos and blah blah.
Yeah,
it's like everything has,
there's a phoniness to every industry,
especially when there's money involved.
But when you get out here,
there's an extremely talented people and creative people and then you get like
great,
uh,
like moments like that.
Like,
uh,
I know a comic I started off with in,
in Boston,
Tony Vee,
I don't if you remember this,
you remember that those old luggage commercials at the,
was it the tourist or commercials or whatever?
And there was the gorilla throwing the,
the luggage around inside the cell.
Vague memory.
Yes.
Yeah,
he played the gorilla.
So that was one of my first,
like cool stories.
He told me that was on the road with them.
I was like,
that was you on the suit?
He's like,
yeah,
that was me.
It's good.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I'm with the fucking,
the gorilla suit guy throwing the,
uh,
the luggage around.
So
I was doing a scoring session for a movie and there was a standup bass guy.
There's two standup bass guys,
actually.
One was younger,
one was a little bit older and uh,
and they were doing this one solo piece for me.
We were in the mixing stage.
And,
uh,
the younger I goes,
you've been know who this other guy is.
And I said,
no,
I'm sorry.
You know,
I don't,
and the younger guy goes,
just show him,
just show him.
And the other guy was okay.
And he starts going [inaudible] noon to doon doon doon doon ended at any,
had played the opening baseline for Nancy Sinatra as these,
for walking the fuck.
Yeah.
It was incredible.
That was over at capital a that was in a cab.
But this was on a different,
when we were at war at the time.
And,
and it was like,
Holy Shit.
And I was like,
where did that come from?
He's like,
you know,
I was just trying different things out.
We tried that and it worked.
And it's like,
that's one of the most iconic baselines.
You just shook his head,
you shook the hand that played that and then every time just did it for me.
It was great.
Yeah.
And every time you hear it,
um,
as always,
I go on tangents on here.
So,
uh,
getting back to the movie,
where can people see this?
Cause that was the thing that came onsite.
Well we came out in November.
This is the thing though.
It's not like no one saw it.
It's just,
it hasn't been where people are gonna see it.
And I feel like what I'm starting to realize,
it was little as I know about this whole movie game,
is that people nowadays like to get them to go out to theaters.
It has to be like a big Aquaman's marble thing.
It's seams.
Or like get like a chick flick like that.
A star is,
well,
it has to be an event of some kind to get you,
uh,
to get you out.
Let's,
it's expensive.
I mean,
look,
it's going to cost a fortune to go to the movies and uh,
uh,
and you have to have a real reason.
You want to want to go with people.
And,
and now the size of these frigging flatscreen TVs,
it's like you really do have like your own movie scream.
No one's going to be talking.
You can hit pause.
So,
um,
this movie,
the front runner is a great one to sit down and watch without the distractions
of going to the movie theater,
I think.
And,
and what I love,
what I fucking loved about this movie when I finally saw it,
um,
was how you don't do that fucking thing that I hate movies where you lead people
around them.
Like you have a point.
Yeah,
I'm trying to make and you know,
and,
and I'm gonna and you know,
if even have half a brain,
you know what the point is as the movies starting and then you're going to hit
me over the head with it for a half hour and a half,
two hours,
your thing is just sort of like,
hey,
this happened and,
and you know,
you can kindness.
It's not,
uh,
you know,
there's certain people that would have done that and had been like,
and if he got elected,
I remember Walker,
we're not an eye rack and all of America works out and it's just kind of like,
no,
this fucking happened.
And ever since then,
um,
all this other stuff is happening and is,
is this,
you know,
one of the questions that I was left with that is does this type of shit make
qualified?
Probably better candidates not run because they have their priorities straight.
Like my family's more important than putting them through this shit.
And does it,
does it more attract just a singularly focused almost.
I don't want to use sociopath cause that's always overused,
but like more of a psycho selfish fucking person where they're going to be like,
yeah,
fuck I don't,
I'm not even thinking about it.
My kids,
I want this.
If you look at the difference between even like Gary Hart and Bill Clinton,
Gary Hart was a guy who said,
I'm just not going to dignify these questions and an answer.
And Bill Clinton was a fighter and that's one of the reasons he became
president.
It's cause he's a guy who just fought back.
Uh,
whether that's a good or bad quality.
But look,
I'm not a guy who believes in good or evil.
That's not why I make movies.
So That's interesting to me.
So what is your
cause I often think that,
you know,
we're like with religion that I grew up in,
it's like if you do this,
you do this and didn't do this,
you're going to hell unless you confess it,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
And then you have to be sincerely to confession.
But I sit there and I like from my religion,
I always think I'm going to hell.
But then I look at my friends,
right?
And
we've all roughly know your friends are roughly living the same life you do.
I look at them and I think all of them are going to heaven.
We're all flawed.
And,
and look,
I love star wars as much as the next guy.
I Love Star Wars and I look forward to every star wars films.
And those movies are all about good and evil.
Uh,
and I appreciate superhero films.
But you know,
so far the kinds of movies that I've been making have not been about good naval.
There've been about nuance even about people who live in the middle.
And,
and,
and frankly,
I think that life is more complex than that.
You can't judge a person,
any person by one moment,
but we are living right now in a time when everyone is judged by one moment
they're judged by what a millisecond.
And you know,
you say one wrong thing and the rest of your life is kind of thrown down the
drain and we lose qualified people because of that.
And then I also love people who then pile on and use that person's fuck up is
the way to show how awesome they are.
Oea,
exactly like the amount of people that have used these,
the,
the victims of sexual assault,
the amount of people who have used that as a platform to show how,
I hate to use this word woke.
They are in like,
look,
I'm on the right side of this and I'm an ally.
And all those Dell that,
that,
uh,
that jargon that has come out of that thing.
And you said something earlier about how,
um,
Gary Hart was,
I'm not going to dignify that in,
in somebody's personal life has done of their business.
I,
I've felt that my whole life and I still feel that.
And there's been times,
um,
you know,
someone's wanting to show me something.
It's just like,
dude,
that's,
that's none of my fucking business.
Especially,
you know,
like texting between two people in somebody,
like somehow gets that.
I always think like the story here is who got that and what a legal way they got
that.
Like why did you,
or anytime in a shitty friend they are.
Yeah.
And why,
why does anybody,
like anytime anybody gets arrested and that the TMZ somehow gets the Mugshot,
it's like,
why isn't there an investigation to find out who's the cop that fucking let that
thing out?
And with a monk,
the monk.
And that's why we have so no,
but that,
no,
that's one of those things that,
uh,
that is public,
but,
but you're right,
it,
that there's plenty that is,
uh,
that is nuanced and more complicated and it kind of gets thrown under the rug.
And what's interesting about the heart story and why we made the front runner is
it brings up 10 different conversations.
It's talking about and not only the relationship between journalists and
politicians and why we vote for certain people.
It's bringing up all kinds of gender politics questions.
Right.
That have changed since that moment.
And we're like,
what the idea of a whistleblower is because Donna Rice wasn't a whistle blower.
Nope.
Like it's easy to forget that,
that there have been whistleblowers who are women who are bravely coming forward
and talking about what kind of dirt bags they've dealt with.
Donna Rice was a private human being.
It's my religion.
Gary Hart and Donna Rice were two very religious people and very private people
who wound up in a very public moment.
Cause we all thought it was our business when neither of them to this day have,
have spoken about it.
Yeah,
I didn't even know
that.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Donna Rice never sold her story.
Best coach,
you know?
Then right there.
Then she's all right.
She's like a,
she's like a mobster who never told on the other mobsters and just went to jail.
Is that a bad analogy?
Did I fuck up?
No,
no,
no.
Not at all.
I mean,
she's complex.
she's a,
it's interesting because,
uh,
I,
I think there's probably a lot of liberals that went to s if they saw front
runner,
they want to kind of take up the torch with Donna Rice and then they find out
that she's,
uh,
she's out in the right wing and she's actually,
you know,
pro life and she's,
I love when that happens through this soap and there's so many.
Do you know,
like,
we know what blew my mind the other day was there was a story about a guy in New
York who killed this pregnant woman and,
uh,
she was early on pregnant and you know,
I,
I forget because of sue,
if some new abortion law they couldn't get,
they couldn't get them on two murders.
It was,
the whole thing was fucking weird.
But the whole gray area in that,
I know,
I know.
I only have like half the fucking details here.
It was something about it.
She was pregnant.
This guy killed her and people were upset that that uh,
because of some new abortion law called the double homicide,
you'd be saying that that is life in the womb and if it's life in the womb then
you cannot have an abortion because that would be murderer.
That's then it becomes this whole thing like,
okay,
so if she wants to have an abortion then it's not a life.
So it's basically life.
If the woman decides like I was sitting there like the amount of like mental
flip flop and I was doing going like,
so what is going on?
Like there was such like a a really,
you know,
I mean obviously it's a horrible thing that happened,
but it was,
it was interesting religiously,
legally and like social media way like politicizing Platt and I'm like how the,
well how the fuck do you navigate that minefield if you're pro choice.
Yeah.
Okay.
And you just say that has to feed assessed not a life,
but if a guy comes in and kills somebody,
then now because she wanted to keep it,
then it is a life,
then it is the taking of life.
Then it becomes like,
well,
wait a minute.
So what do we fucking say in here saying,
Oh God,
I don't have to figure that kind of thing for a living,
like Q.
Imagine having to be the person who has to decide that.
No,
because I'll be honest with you,
like my,
I have my opinions on abortion,
but like I had,
I always preface them with like,
I have no fucking idea what the right answer is here because I look at it one
way.
It's like,
well,
if,
if it's not the taking of a life than,
but if you didn't have that procedure,
they would have been another life,
you know,
barring a miscarriage or something like that.
So something was ended there.
But then on the other side,
you look at like,
uh,
you look at like the population control and like the way we're polluting the
planet and how that's affecting all these other babies that are alive.
I mean,
I think there's like a million fucking ways that you can look at it.
So I just sort of resigned it to,
uh,
like whatever somebody feels is so is the right thing to do.
If they're cool with that,
you know,
then then I'm,
I'm fine with it.
I have approached choice then.
I mean,
that's choice then because I mean,
what you're talking about is choice.
Cause I don't mind,
I wouldn't do it right to kind of do,
yeah,
but you're talking about someone's right to choose themselves,
which I agree with you about.
Uh,
people need personal freedom and I also don't like people telling me what the
full,
but I don't mind that.
I don't mind.
Like,
you know,
I liked it.
His laws.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't take it to that level where I'm like,
murder bill.
I'm sorry.
Hey,
if you want to kill somebody and it's not me.
I mean,
who am I to say that that guy didn't deserve it?
No,
I'm all right.
Taking a little break here.
It's time for a little bit of advertising a,
by the way,
thank you to everybody came out in Santa bad breath in Pasadena in and a
Riverside.
I really appreciate it.
I had a great time at all of those shows and I got to come home and sleep in my
own bed.
Unbelievable.
All right.
Here's some fucking reads for you there.
He looks everybody.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
You're so special.
You're a warrior.
You're living your best life,
so why would you buy a generic mattress built for everyone else,
especially a white male.
Next,
please mention all the taking,
taking points to talking points below.
Oh,
absolutely.
He likes sleep built asleep quiz that takes two minutes to complete and they use
the answers to match your body type and sleep preferences to the mattress when
you're asleep.
A side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
Jesus,
it's getting weird here like a plush or firm bed with helux humans.
There's no more guessing or confusion.
Just go to helix,
sleep.com/bird take their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
mattress while they build your robot replacement.
That will give you the best sleep of your life for couples.
Helix Helix can even split the mattress down the middle,
like a divorce.
Providing individual support.
Enough was a divorce.
She get the whole bed cause she feels to a big match with lifestyle,
providing individual support needs and feel preferences for each side.
That's right.
Feel preferences.
They have a 10 year warranty and you get to try it out for a hundred nights.
Risk free.
Right now he looks telus is offering up to 200 bucks off mattresses.
Mattress orders for their president's Day sale.
Get up to $200 at helix sleep.com/burr that's heloc sleep.com/burr for $200 off
your mattress.
Order for their president's Day sale going on right now.
Helix,
helix,
sleep.com/bar h.
E.
L.
I.
X.
Oh look who's here.
Everybody had sold zip
hiring youth to be hard.
It sounds like an old man talking about his dick.
Multiple job sites,
stacks of resumes,
a confusing review process.
But today hiring can be easy and you only have to go to one place to get it
done.
Zip recruiter.com/burr well all zip
sends your job to over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
But they don't stop there with their powerful matching technology zap.
That was the Marco Polo one scan styluses of resumes to find people with the
right experience and invite them to apply to your job.
As applications come in and zip
analyzes each one in spots,
lights the spotlights,
the top candidates,
so you never miss a great match.
Zip
was so effective that 80% of employees who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the first day.
And right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter.
Yay.
Grown up for free at this exclusive website address.
ziprecruiter.com/decode that's ziprecruiter.com/per zip,
weaker.com/prep
that was the falling off the clip.
Read Zip,
The smartest way to hire,
uh,
all right,
movement MVMT now.
Now it's time and now it's time to move on to our all time.
Favorite underdog's success story.
Evidently MVMT movement watches founded on the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank.
They've sold almost 2 million watches worldwide by bringing quality designs and
a fair price movement.
Watches are all about looking good while keeping it simple.
They don't tell you how many steps you take in a blow your blow what or blow
your wrist up with text messages,
parentheses you up.
Oh,
the old booty call and the risks that,
uh,
let me funny if you're rubbing one out and then that came in,
it's like,
oh,
I don't need to do this.
No,
they're not overly intrusive on life with notifications,
text messages,
emails,
et Cetera.
They tell time,
uh,
like true classic time pieces should looking good doing it.
Movement watches start at just 95 bucks.
You're looking at $400 for the same quality from a traditional brand.
Uh,
talk about all the things you can buy with the save money.
What's the 400 minus nine?
It's $305.
Well,
I didn't want to tell you what I first thought of.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I can't say that it was something that was a pro choice that you could pay.
Three quarters of Moveon has almost 2 million watches in over 160 countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash l z movement,
new styles on their site all the time.
Check out their latest m t@mvmt.com go to movement.com/burr,
uh,
join the move movement,
m v m t.com/burr.
All right,
let's get back to the interview here with the wonderful Jason Reitman.
But anyway,
so now we didn't have any mentioned,
where can people see this fucking amazing movie that you made with,
with Hugh Jackman and Vera Farmiga the two of them.
I was watching this shit gone.
They're gonna get,
they're going to get nominated for something.
It's a fucking,
uh,
just weird time in,
in this business where a movie like yours,
it can,
can slip through the cracks in cinema.
But the great thing though is it can now be on like a Netflix or something like
that and it can explode.
So it's not even like,
so the jury's still out as far as where it's self.
Well,
it's on Itunes,
on iTunes.
Okay.
You can get the DVD and it's a love letter to 1970 cinema.
So if you happen to be a sinner file like me and you did that stuff and you did
guys like Robert Altman and Michael Ritchie.
I mean this is a love letter to their movies.
There's lots of these crazy long,
you know oners uh,
and uh,
I,
I love those shots because yeah,
I feel especially with the way people edit now where they make everything look
like the fucking Bourne identity,
which works for the Bourne identity.
But yeah,
I have this theory that when you edit really quick like that,
it's like you're flipping through channels and it makes your brain reset,
reset,
reset.
And where the long holding shots draws you in.
Like I kind of learned that when I was first started doing standup specials,
I would look at the old ones.
It'd be like,
why does this look so fucking real?
And everything from today it looks fake now.
Part of it was HD because you know,
HD can get like clearer than real life.
Yeah.
Like you'd have on a blue like a soap opera.
Like your blue sweater.
All of a sudden I'm just,
I'm not even listening to you.
I'm like,
God,
look how blue his fucking sweaters,
you know?
Um,
but then the other thing was the pacing of it was just Bam,
Bam.
Specially in the two thousands.
It was a really bad time for standup specials where there was just a lot of like
great comics where I heard the,
what I felt that the editing hurt the material,
um,
where you would just have directors just like just shooting if fucking load of
every,
every camera.
I mean,
I watched his special,
literally like a guy walking out to the microphone.
The guy showed every camera he had rare.
We're in front of them,
were behind him.
I'm at the top of the theater.
I'm swooping in the Jibs my favorite thing ever,
ever in,
in a,
uh,
in a standup special.
Why am I swooping in to my shit show,
right?
And nothing else and nothing makes me feel less like I'm in the audience.
Then I'm flying over the audience.
I hate that.
Yeah.
Well,
we talked about the idea.
You brought the idea up to me was,
you know,
could we shoot a comedy special on film?
Shoot it like an old rock doc.
Yeah.
I mean I made a short,
uh,
a short documentary on roast battle that they do up in the,
the bellows.
Yeah.
That gets crazy.
And uh,
and that was fun.
We shot a black and white and made it all grainy and it made it look punk rock.
And I was,
that was a lot of fun.
You wake when people see of you,
put that out,
you know,
I,
I've kept that one secret.
[inaudible] we brought it to Sundance and a played there.
And if I know someone,
I'll just send them a link so they can watch it.
Cause I think it's really cool,
but I don't know why I've kept that one.
Uh,
I've kept that one tight.
But that's something you,
you're gonna you'll use.
I don't know.
I just,
uh,
well I love the roast bad.
I love what they do up there.
I love that.
It's one of the few rooms that is just honest anymore.
Uh,
when I go in and watch that and it's these tight room,
there's only hold,
you know,
less than a hundred people.
And it's also,
it's Tuesday at midnight.
So the only reason you're there is if you really need to be there.
And,
and it's the least prejudice room and most prejudice room I've ever been in my
life.
I actually,
I actually was there Tuesday night,
uh,
doing it,
running my hour,
cause I'm going to be doing this taping a special.
And,
uh,
it's just one of those great comedy things where,
I forget her name,
the woman who was running the show,
but she was great,
but it,
the,
the crowd was very progressive as I should.
And that's in quotes because progressive just means think what we think or we're
going to attack you,
not progressive.
So I went up there and I was doing my shit and Oh my God,
I was fucking bombing so bad for like the first 10 minutes before I kind of,
you know,
got out of,
it was making fun of Michelle Obama doing the arena tour,
which is just fucking hilarious to me.
Um,
and I knew that,
that they were all going to be,
and that got you the inspiration.
Uh,
so I just had it so I was trashing her even harder.
But um,
it was just one of those things that makes the comedy store great and make stand
up comedy great.
Where it's just like,
like I was up there bombing and I was having the best fucking,
like I was annoying the crowds so bad that there was a woman in the crowd
pretending to be asleep on her friend's shoulder like that was going to,
uh,
I was getting under your skin.
I said,
oh my God.
And I loved it and I just kept,
I kept talking to her to the point she had to pretend to wake up and then I was
critiquing her soap opera acting.
I was like,
okay,
now in this take,
let's do it this way.
And what's funny is I've been doing this shift for 27 years.
It's like,
do you think that's the first fucking time so much?
I remember,
I remember the first time that it happened to me,
the old Boston comedy club,
and there was these two big black women in the front row.
And one of them just like put her head down on the other one.
And,
but this is the thing,
I was bombing during that set too,
but I was bombing in a bad way.
I was bombing like,
I'm not funny.
The other night I was bombing like,
well,
you're not receptive to my material.
And I know that.
So then I'm just going to go like even harder.
I saw you do this and before you and I met,
uh,
and in a moment we should talk about our first conversation when you got to set,
because I don't think you knew who I was.
I thought you was somebody else.
It was just kind of amazing.
I
was so bad.
It was amazing.
It made me so happy.
You have no idea.
So,
uh,
I thought you were going to be like,
why did I hire this guy?
What a fucking more,
I know.
Oh no,
he's spectacular.
So,
uh,
I saw you,
do you remember Tig Notaro had a show at Largo and you did that show and it was
very similar.
I mean it was,
takes crowd and ticks,
brilliant.
And her crowd and she's one of my favorites,
one of my favorite audiences.
Uh,
obviously it'd be very left wing and,
and I watched you do this kind of set where you realized,
oh,
the audience is just so uncomfortable with anything other than leftwing
material.
And because of that,
they don't know if they're allowed to laugh.
And you just came right at the audience with fearlessly and with confidence.
And uh,
it was a delight.
It was what's
ticks fans?
They're not really violent.
So I,
there wasn't really wasn't,
I didn't have to be to fearless.
It'd be if it was a,
I was open at four a,
I dunno,
a couple other comics I can think of.
They have a more aggressive,
like I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be fearless in front of a Joe Rogan crowd.
Cause I would figure a lot of them know that UFC stuff.
And I would be afraid to piss somebody off in the crowd because those guys are
no joke.
It takes audience.
You're just to get a stern letter while they might end your career,
if they might start a Hashtag,
if you say the wrong thing,
I mean who I might get put on the sidelines.
I don't know.
It's a really weird thing.
And this definitely,
um,
there's definitely,
uh,
places that I go to now where it's just like good Lord.
One of them is New York City.
I swear to God.
I mean really,
if I go in on just a guest spot night,
if I go there to do a show,
it's people who know me,
they know what they're getting and then,
you know,
it's,
it's actually easy.
But if I go in and just pop in and do like,
like I will never ever get over having a joke being groaned in New York City.
It's like,
I'm just thinking like,
what the fuck happened in this play?
The whole fucking place.
It's like a giant bed bath and beyond now.
It's so nice.
It's so much fucking cleaner.
I Dunno where they put all those people because all of the,
all of the social ills that created that they haven't solved.
There's still drug addicts.
There's still prostitution.
I just don't know what Rod,
they swept them underneath too.
Cause I know it exists,
but now everybody's walking around and like the fucking Truman show and you
literally stand on stage and what fucking blows my mind.
It's like I always say I'm sick.
I'm 50 years old.
Like you guys should be shocking me.
You guys were all,
you're acting like a bunch of old people on a fucking cruise ship.
Like I'll be up in like,
oh,
you know,
but what I love about that is only a fit.
It fucks with their politics because since the beginning of my career,
you can say that a redneck has sex with his own sister and you will get an
applause break and be carried out the fucking room.
And right there,
um,
there's some sort of incest going there at some sort there is,
right.
But that's totally fine because it's those people,
you can say whatever the fuck you want about them.
But then everybody over here is,
is courageous.
And there were a warrior in a fucking,
I dunno what else they are.
Well,
we're missing nuance right now and we're missing conversation and it's
absolutely good and evil now.
It is,
absolutely.
It's your,
your side or my side and there's no real,
there's not enough Patrice O'Neil because I gotta be honest with you.
Like if that guy was still around,
he was like,
uh,
like sort of the comedy bouncer or policemen.
And to the point there was like people who wouldn't work clubs that he was at
because,
and they would say,
because he's a bully,
he's a fucking asshole.
He was actually,
he was just trying to make you better.
And like the whole like,
I mean,
I,
I miss that guy,
you know,
at least once a week something will happen.
I'd be like,
Ah,
God,
I wish I could hear what Patrice would've said about that.
And I can't,
I can't fucking imagine what he would be thinking today with some of the shit
that,
and some of the people that say it like the level of like,
I mean,
I hope I'm not coming off as preachy cause I would never tell another comic or
anybody what they should or shouldn't be saying.
You know,
if you asked my advice,
I'd be like,
listen,
this.
And I always say,
this is how I did it.
And it worked out for me because with our business there is no,
you start in the mail room,
right?
And then you get promoted here.
It's like I always pictured it's a giant field and everybody's running in every
different direction.
And some they,
somebody you see somebody punched through whenever he's like,
oh,
that's the direction in this fucking direction,
you know?
So,
um,
well you actually said something that I tell the young filmmakers all the time,
writers and directors,
uh,
and I find that when I meet young writers,
directors,
and I have to imagine it's the same for comics,
that when you're young,
you imitate the people that you admire.
In my first short films,
all you would say is,
wow,
that guy really wants to be Quentin Tarantino.
I get it.
You Love Tarantino.
And then,
and then,
and after you imitate a bunch of the people that you like,
you,
you realize that you've been scared of saying something or writing sung or
directing something in his way that the back of your head is telling you to do
it.
Yep.
And you're embarrassed to that voice.
And then,
and then every once in a while you start to lean into that voice and that's your
voice.
And if you can,
if you can stop being scared of it and stop imitating the people you like and
actually start to grow a little bit of confidence with the way that you just
naturally want it to say things,
that is the only way in a,
it's the only authentic way.
And I think it kind of,
it,
it's not only for any art form,
it's kind of any walk of life.
Uh,
there's the moment you stop being scared of who you actually were born.
Um,
you thought,
I always said that.
Every comic on an open mic,
walks in with their voice and then they get introduced and then that walk,
they proceed to lose their voice and then try to find it because you go up
there,
right.
And it's like before you got on stage,
I mean,
people ask you questions and you just answer them or at least amongst your
friends and you're totally yourself.
But that is such an outer body experience on my God taking the Mick out of the
mic stand and then you're just totally self conscious and then it disappears and
then you'll,
you'll spend the next seven,
eight fucking 20 years trying to find it again.
How long did it take you?
Um,
yeah.
Hmm.
I would say
yeah,
I would say I don't,
it's a,
okay.
I Dunno,
somewhere in the two thousands I started to get it and then I,
but I feel like since like 2011 2012 I've really been me.
Or maybe it's just,
but you also changed.
So a lot of times you look back at yourself 10 years ago and you can't relate to
yourself.
So maybe I was being me,
but that's just who I was then.
I don't really know,
but it was it how many years though?
All right.
So I,
I,
you're looking at yourself and you're going,
oh,
I know who I'm pretending to be.
Well,
my thing,
I started in [inaudible] 92 and my thing was,
uh,
Brian Regan.
Okay.
Uh,
and then Dave Attell was a huge one.
Dave,
Dave Louie.
Um,
but I thought,
it's funny,
I didn't really,
like there wasn't anything about Louie where like he blew,
didn't have like this cadence that got into my head.
It was more his,
his presence when he came on to this day,
I'm at one to,
I always tell this story,
he went on at the Boston and it was like fucking like,
the show was just over.
It was like two in the morning.
It was fucking over it.
Nobody had even gotten a laugh and like 45 minutes,
everybody's just going up there bombing and he just walked on stage is that
booming voice and he did this exaggerated wave and it just went,
hello.
I can't even tell how we did it,
but it was so ridiculous and exaggerated and silly that he just sort of broke
them and they started like laughing and then he just went into his shit and
immediately started murdering and killing so hard.
You would have thought we all did a good job,
like keeping the show going.
Right.
And I remember seeing him do it,
Chappelle do it.
Dave Attell,
dewerd Greer Barnes,
all of these guys.
And that was the big thing as a comics being so scared of the village.
Okay.
In the mid nineties where it was,
Giuliani had just taken over,
just parked that police truck down in the fucking,
um,
Washington square park.
But it's like,
you know,
it's people like,
dealing drugs out front of it was like,
you know,
the shit that people saw on the way to the show.
That's why the grounds in New York blows my mind because it used to be like,
what the fuck can I do to wake these people up after what they just saw on the,
just just getting to this club.
But I used to watch those guys and just watch them kill after everybody bombed
for like an hour and just two in the morning,
start killing like they were nine o'clock at night in a,
in a,
in a perfect spot.
And I remember just standing back there going,
how the fuck do you do that?
Like how,
how do,
how do you get to that level?
Um,
but anyways,
I don't want to be sitting here talking about myself cause you have now your
next movie,
you don't gotta be directing the next star.
Ghostbusters.
Yeah.
Right.
So now you're going from this,
this nuance thing that now you got to do this,
this franchise move.
By the way,
congratulations.
I mean that's,
that's a huge one.
Well,
I mean,
and it's not just this last movie,
it's the last 20 years of my life.
I,
you know,
like any son of any father,
I just said,
I'm not going to be you.
And went out and became a Sundance film maker.
You know,
you know,
I establish myself at Sundance.
I played that festival many times,
a short films.
I established myself as an independent filmmaker.
And,
and that's who I really still see myself.
And if you would ask me anytime in the last 20 years,
you know,
are you going to direct the Ghostbusters movie?
My answer would've been no,
no,
I'm an artist.
Yeah.
That's just not who I am.
That's my dad.
You must have me confused,
you know,
all that garbage.
And um,
and I had an idea of how did id actually for a while it was just a cool way.
Who directed the first one?
My father.
Your father did,
I'm sorry.
I'm the worst dude.
Like all I know is sports.
So your dad directed the first one [inaudible] we started talking sports and uh,
all sound very ignorant.
But uh,
graduations on the super bowl.
I know that.
Thank you.
I did a hell of a job watching all year waiting for my ring to show up.
But yeah,
my drag drag.
My Dad directed the first and second Ghostbusters.
So wait a minute.
Did you,
um,
wait.
And they recently made another,
so this is the fourth one.
He and my father produced,
uh,
the one that came out a couple of years ago.
The one that Paul Feig directed.
Okay.
So has there ever been in the history of Hollywood,
a dad who directed a,
the beginning of a franchise and then his son comes along later and,
and,
and directs another one?
I don't know.
And there's a good question and I probably should know the answer to this.
Uh,
and there's only so many kind of fog inside.
So basically right now,
okay,
you got,
uh,
Lawrence Kasdan is the guy who wrote empire strikes back,
Raiders of the lost Ark and a,
and was actually a neighbor growing up and he has two sons.
Both are directors,
John and Jake.
Uh,
Jake most famously directed Jumanji John,
uh,
cowrote the Han solo movie with his father.
So you'll have that is you got,
I saw that one,
that one,
I saw that on a plane and then,
and then Lawrence and his son,
right solo.
So you'll have that father son thing.
Uh,
other than that,
oh wait a minute.
That's just going to try.
Is it driver Adam driver?
Oh,
Adam driver out of drivers in the is in the kind of,
uh,
is in this edition of the Skywalker that the one I saw drivers in force awakens
Adam drivers.
And last Jad I they got,
I know you've got Carl Reiner and Rob Reiner,
but I don't think rob Reiner ever directed anything that his father established.
Uh,
I dunno.
Maybe like Sofia Coppola does a godfather movie.
I know,
but she was in one,
she was in the third one now.
Okay.
So,
but when do you know,
when do you,
when you're doing something that fucking
big [inaudible] like I just can't,
I'm like how far out do you have to start with to,
to keep that fucking giant pizza dough in the air as far as like,
it's instantly the crazy thing.
Yeah.
Is we have no time is we,
so I wrote the film in secret with my writing partner,
Gil Canon.
We wrote it over the last year while we were finishing up front runner and we
turned it in December.
And I have to admit,
my presumption was it was going to be like any studio film that I had heard
about where they do years of rewrites and they grind it into the ground and it
never happens.
And I was kind of fully prepared for this year to be a year of maybe taking a
little time off and you know,
doing rewrites on Ghostbusters and instead this the studio read the first draft
and said,
yeah,
go make it.
Wow.
So we're,
I mean with,
with a very short runway,
we're going to be shooting,
uh,
you know,
the summer.
Good Lord,
I ain't coming out the following summer.
How long will it take you to shoot something like that?
Uh,
I don't know.
I mean it'll take us a few months and then we'll be in post and for the first
time I'll have set pieces with visual effects and they'll be working with a
visual effects supervisor and you know,
visual effects houses,
they'll be crate and ghosts and things like,
have you ever,
when you got into early on in your career as a director,
did you ever get into the edit room?
And realize you didn't have a shot you needed.
And then like what the fuck do I do now?
Like,
Oh,
I've realized that on every single movie.
I mean,
you go into every single movie,
uh,
thinking you know how to do this job and you get to the edit and it is
humiliating and depressing and you,
you watch that first cut of your movie.
And,
and I've had,
you know,
I've had movies that went on to be nominated for best picture.
And the first time I saw them I thought I will never get hired again.
No one will ever let me direct a movie again when they see this.
Yeah.
Oh God.
I mean,
look the greatest,
because I would say as,
as like an actor when I sit there and you know,
when you first start,
especially as a comedian,
you know,
you exist in realtime to 20 minutes and you're done in 20 minutes to then see
how long it takes to get 20 minutes of film is something,
uh,
I had to lie,
I got to get into a completely different mindset.
And when I saw like all of the shots,
not necessarily on your movie,
cause I thought I liked the pace you worked at there.
There's been a couple ones that I've,
I've worked in where there's shooting so much stuff I'd find lasic why would
they do,
and then I finally just put myself into the director's brain and I was like,
oh,
I bet every one of them early in their career went into the edit room,
didn't have the shot,
and that like fucking haunts them.
So I feel like they get in there,
they get everything that they want and then then like,
then they start going,
okay,
all right,
what were,
how could this fuck me,
you know?
All right,
let's,
let's not,
no,
now let's do like a tracking thing and all that type of stuff.
So,
and ever since I've,
I've,
I did that,
I kind of,
it's like I understand the madness of it because I was doing,
what most people do initially was I was in my own head looking at my own head,
like,
why isn't this going the way I would do it?
Even though I don't understand what's going on.
Like I just recently did an acting gig and for the first time ever I finally it,
I don't know what happened.
It all came together.
Like I got it.
I'm like,
okay,
the shooting the master,
now they're doing this over and now they're going for a two shot and I could
kind of,
and then I started being like an actor going like laid back.
They're not going to be on me.
I mean they're on me,
but they're not going to use this.
Yeah.
So you know,
make sure this one,
now this is one that they're going to go to.
So make sure this and the,
I never had that.
I was just always out there,
you know,
paging Mr. Herman.
There's to her made you have a phone,
call it the front now I would be,
I would be doing my clothes up.
Acting on the fucking wide.
Yeah,
it's throughout the whole fucking thing.
And I,
and that would be working with these actions going like,
this guy doesn't even look like he's fucking trying.
And then all of a sudden that they'd be over me and all of a sudden like,
boom,
fuck is that guy.
And I was like,
what is going on here man?
This guy is like a fucking,
and he's like a skitzo or something.
Um,
I it,
this last one that I just did it all.
It all came together and,
and I,
and I ended up,
I got it and I got,
I finally understood what I was supposed to be doing and how I could help the
director and everybody else.
And,
and I ended up having the best fucking time.
I'm,
even though I bitched about it a little bit,
a cup,
not even a little,
just every night.
Like Jesus Christ,
12 hour fucking days.
I'm a comedian.
I work one hour,
one hour days.
I found that actors generally break down into two groups and there's actors who
are 100% aware of everything that's happening around them.
And then there's actors who have no idea what's happening around them.
And they're both valuable,
right?
Actors who are kind of puppeteering themselves and know where the camera is and
note the lending is going to do.
And you know,
Clooney's like that.
Clooney,
you know,
uh,
who was a director himself will literally be like,
so you want me to bring my right shoulder in and I'm going to look this way and
when I look all,
you know,
I'll keep that one look.
And what Lens are you on?
Oh,
you're on a 50.
Okay,
great.
I'll look that one.
And he knows the whole thing.
And then I've have actors who are equally talented,
but like if I had an actress,
uh,
exceptional actress who mid scene I had to cut and I said,
you know,
you can't stand there.
And she said,
why?
I said,
you standing right in front of the camera.
I had no idea.
Literally it was just blocking leverage had just stopped.
But there's a brilliance to that cause there's so lost in what they're doing.
So then you have to adjust it when I can,
if I can capture it.
The best scenes when you have one of each.
I find you have one actor who knows everything that's going on and you've got
the other who's wild and it's like,
it's like you have one dance partner who's keeping time and keeping the foot
work.
And the other one who's just pushing them and it was just a theory will and it's
going to give you stuff you would have never thought of that.
I probably don't want to know any more of this cause then it'll all be in my
head the next time I do it.
It's something that
I want to hang out with.
You got to explain that Lens thing cause I've,
I've heard a few actors,
what are you on a 50 all right,
so you're right,
right.
Like they know like the whole thing,
I'm like I,
it's,
it's oddly so simple.
I mean it really is just one shows a lot in one shows less and one has more and
focused in,
one has less and focus and they make you feel different things and that,
and that's just it.
So when you talk about all the things that directors,
there's an art to all of that.
Well you're,
you're,
you're either someone who is sensitive or not.
You're either someone,
and I think the same goes for a comic.
You're either someone who sends it enough to know,
oh,
when I say this,
it makes the room feel like this.
It makes them laugh in this way versus that way.
And when I use this word,
it makes them laugh in this way versus that way.
And over time you get to,
you know,
I mean very rarely,
but you get to someone as talented as yourself who has an opening,
say you later and idea that they're going to start with.
But from there on,
you're figuring your way out and you're reading a room and you're sensitive to
it.
And the same way a director is sensitive to,
all right,
if I light it this way,
it'll make the audience feel this way.
If I cut it this way or use this music could use this shot,
uh,
all the day down to kind of my new details.
And your,
your ability to grow as a filmmaker is your sensitivity matched with kind of
growing technique?
Right.
Well,
last question I'll ask you.
All right.
Thank you so much for coming on.
This has been fascinating listening to all how all of this sludge to be here.
Um,
so with the ghostbuster movie,
yeah,
I would imagine that there's this whole thing where you have to be loyal to the
look,
the vibe and the fans of the previous,
and then you also have to want to put like your stamp on it.
So how is this like a Hacky fucking junket question?
Like,
no,
not at all.
And this is knocking.
I'm not making the Juno of Ghostbusters movies.
Uh,
uh,
once again,
I don't know.
That reference was super bowl of movies that I said Daddy,
that's that,
that,
that's probably my most famous movie.
Like my obituary will say,
uh,
Jason Reitman son of Ivan Reitman,
director of Ghostbusters also directed Juno.
That will be my,
that's how my obituary starts.
Uh,
is that your biggest movie?
Yeah.
And it was this kind of movie that we made for nothing was a movie that we made
for like $7 million and grossed like $200 million.
And so you made like 30 grand on that note.
I made nothing cause it was my second movie and I literally had nothing on it.
But they always gets you a studio,
made a fortune on that movie.
They did really well.
And it was the launching of Ellen page in Diablo Cody wrote it.
And uh,
and really use the reason why I have a career.
Um,
but um,
anyhow,
uh,
this is going to be a love letter to Ghostbusters.
I,
um,
I love this franchise.
I grew up watching it.
I consider myself the first Ghostbusters fan.
I was like seven years old when that movie came out.
And uh,
and I love it.
And I want to make a movie for my fellow Ghostbusters Fan.
So it is all a hundred percent sense.
Yeah.
And,
and we're doing it in the style,
like we just did this teaser for it that we launched when we announced it.
And even in that,
we went back to the work files for the sound of the proton pack and we went back
to the stems of Elmer Bernstein score,
uh,
for just where it says at the end of the teaser it says like,
you know,
summer 2020,
we went back and found the original like physical vinyl letters that they use to
create the Ghostbusters poster in 1984.
Oh,
rescan them.
Then,
uh,
our titles guys reprinted them and we filmed,
the title's not like in a computer.
We shot physical titles with a light and smoke effect because that's how they
would have done it back in the day.
So we are in every way trying to go back to original technique and,
and make a and hand the movie back to the fence.
That's awesome.
Well,
I'm looking forward to seeing that and everybody can see the front runner on
iTunes.
Uh,
where else did you say it was available?
I mean anywhere you'd normally go,
go,
go buy a blu.
I go watch and iTunes.
Uh,
and particularly if you're someone who doesn't like being told what to think,
um,
here is kind of a rare movie of new,
yeah.
I love it.
All right,
Jason Reitman everybody,
thank you so much for being on the podcast.
Pleasure Buddy.